incendios devastadores en el
mediterráneo y california inundaciones
inéditas en bélgica y alemania deshielo
en los polos y niños temiendo un nuevo
apocalipsis en eeuu
tengo miedo porque si hace tanto calor
las aguas podrían calentarse demasiado y
todo podría hervir como cuando los
dinosaurios se extinguieron es el miedo
de los adultos del futuro después de que
el grupo intergubernamental de expertos
sobre el cambio climático presentase la
opinión pública su último informe en
inglés indiscutible que las actividades
humanas están provocando el cambio
climático y haciendo que los fenómenos
meteorológicos extremos sean más
frecuentes y severos los científicos
avisan de fenómenos como la subida de
temperaturas o el aumento del nivel del
mar y piden una respuesta inmediata los
científicos pueden producir informes
pero no pueden salvar el mundo del lado
de los gobiernos
las reacciones llegan de forma mediática
así reaccionó en sus redes el presidente
de eeuu al informe de las naciones
unidas'
estamos ansiosos por abordar la crisis
climática las señales son inconfundibles
la ciencia es innegable y el coste de la
inacción
aumentando y así lo hizo el presidente
de francia emmanuel macro el informe de
los expertos es definitivo de nuevo el
tiempo de la indignación ha quedado
atrás mientras desde el activismo
medioambiental van más allá del informe
y piden a los gobiernos más que palabras
bueno no estamos hablando de las causas
de origen de las cosas que alimentan los
eventos extremos y no estamos
responsabilizando a las personas en el
poder un escepticismo con el poder que
empieza a calar entre los que lo
perdieron todo en este caso por las
inundaciones en bélgica
una cosa es publicar informes de alarma
pero los hábitos no están cambiando y
seguimos contaminando tanto como antes
todos los escenarios que se plantean en
el informe son críticos científicos
advierten que el fenómeno podría agravar
la migración climática incluso en el
norte global porque la gravedad de las
catástrofes medioambientales que se
sienten en la actualidad pueden afectar
a todos en cualquier momento